the father of Indie Gregory this poor
child who is uh facing death because the
British government is uh attempting to
kill the child even contrary to what the
government of Italy and what the Vatican
are offering which is citizenship and
treatment at the hospital benino Jesu uh
we have him on the line he's not in
court right now this should be an
international Scandal but because we've
heard this story now every six months at
least every year specifically out of the
United Kingdom we've become callous to
it and the story is that a baby faces
medical problems and the parents of the
baby want to to treat the baby and want
to help the baby and want to keep the
baby alive and the Psychopaths running
the UK government and health system and
more broadly who run the health systems
in the west want to kill the child
because they now view death as
treatment Mr Gregory thank you for
coming on the show thank you thank you
Fe me so sorry about everything you're
going through it's horrific the the
health problems of your child are
obviously horrific in themselves I I
pray to God I never have to go through
anything like that I it's it's uh the
greatest fear any parent has and then on
top of
that your
government will not permit you to treat
your child or keep your child alive and
on top of that the UK government will
not
allow the government of Italy which gave
your child citizenship will not allow
the pope will not allow the Vicor of
Christ on Earth to help treat your child
they simply want to kill your baby
yeah tell us what's what's happening
we're just absolutely disgusted um I'm
embarrassed to be British another minute
you've got another country offering to
pay for the treatment and they're
blocking her from going to Italy they're
blocking her to for coming home to get
excurtion they're just being it's just
so cruel and inhumane we just don't
understand where does the case stand now
I know I I really appreciate you're
making time I know you've got a lot of
other things on your mind I I know that
there was a chance you were going to be
in court this morning or this afternoon
by by your time so where where does it
all stand is there's a cour here and
going off now it's online virtual but
I've just had to pop out to get my
daughter from school and then go back to
the hospital and then join again but
yeah the the appeal is this appeal is to
do with where Indie they're trying to
block Indie from coming home they're
trying to say she can only go to a
hospice or the hospital to have a
treatment withdrawn so they've blocked
us from going it there and now they're
trying to block us from taking home it's
just
cruel is there any is there any hope at
this point that you will be able to
bring your baby to Italy for treatment
at the bino Jesu hospital or is that
completely off the table I know the
Italians are doing as much as they can
in the background and we're just hoping
that something will come of it like at
any point it's it's for the UK
government and the Italian government to
come to some sort of agreement that's
what we're hoping
for now short of that you you'd like to
take your daughter home of course you
know you don't want to ship your
daughter off to a hospice to to just be
neglected officially neglected by the UK
medical system so what is their argument
why won't they allow you to take your
own daughter home if if you know things
are going to go south as I suppose they
will for all of us eventually but if you
know if this is really her time but why
why won't they let her have her her
final moments in her home with her
family who who love her rather than in
some clinical U UK
institution it was it was in the
original court order that she could we
could choose for her to come home I
think when they found out about Italy I
think they got scared and are trying to
block us from taking home because
they're probably scared that we're going
to jump on a on a plane or something and
go go over there that's what it feels
like of course I actually I should have
realized that I because I couldn't
figure out I said it just seems so
needlessly cruel to say you can't even
take your own daughter home if she is
going to die you're not you can't but
right because they don't want you to
flee to flee to go get medical treatment
from Italy and the and the pope from
from the Vatican though now your
daughter is officially an Italian
citizen do I have that right yeah yeah
that's right yeah
exactly as a parent in the UK you've got
when when you go to the courts you've
got no rights you've set up to fail
everybody's against you my daughter's
not brain dead she's moving she's
breathing she's she's alert she this
children in America with the same
disease who was nine um I've been
talking to the parents of them it's just
it's all down to money it's all down to
cost and resources in the
UK so that that's what this is it's it's
not that you know your your daughter
would would
just die IM immediately or anything like
that it's not what they're saying which
is that oh she's in this horrific kind
of pain and it's whatever euth in Asia
quote unquote arguments that they make
it's it's rather that
this is It's a socialist Healthcare
System they've got a finite amount of
money and they just they just don't want
to spend the money to keep your daughter
alive they don't think she's worth the
cost because she's potentially got a
shorter life but nobody knows when
they're going to pass away so they're
not God they shouldn't play this they
don't play God this I I I first covered
the story on the show yesterday and and
the the thing that makes
me it's not the thing that makes me
angriest is what they're doing to your
daughter the thing that makes me second
angriest is that I see what they're
think I see what the judge is thinking I
see what the UK government is thinking I
see their logic the problem is their
premises are wrong and the premises are
wrong for exactly the reason you just
said because they're saying well look
she's going to die eventually yeah
you're going to die eventually too I'm
going to die eventually too you don't
know when you're going to die you maybe
you'll die in 50 years maybe you'll go
get hit by a bus tomorrow does that mean
that we're going to stop feeding you
today does that mean that we're going to
stop giving you basic medical care it's
just so it's just a culture of death
that is so shocking that when it
happened the first couple of times it
was an international Scandal now the
biggest Scandal is that it's not an
international Scandal that not nearly
enough people are talking about this
egregious Injustice that your government
a supposedly civilized government is
doing to you and your family and your
daughter I know it's disgraceful it's
like everyone in the UK is just not
aware of what's happening around them
and you you've got another country Italy
who are doing everything they can and
India wasn't even Italian she's got
Italian C citizenship now but that
country is doing everything they can to
help so why can't my country help why
can't they come to some sort of
agreements why can't my country help why
can't my country help my own daughter
can you imagine that that is that is
such that phrase is such an indictment
of what has happened to the the medical
system and the whole political order in
these countries uh I I know that you're
uh extremely busy Mr Gregory so I'm
going to let you go and I know that
there you know sometimes we say if if
there's a a real uh important
International cause we say well how can
we help where can we donate I know that
what we're talking about here is a
matter of hours or days that the kind of
urgency so of course I encourage
everyone to uh pray for you and your
family and for your daughter that there
is a a happy conclusion you know e even
as unlikely as that seems right now a
priest friend of mine a British priest
friend of mine pointed out once that
prayer is not the last resort prayer is
the first Resort and so we will all
absolutely be praying for you um if
there's if there's any other way that we
can help uh you know please do please do
let us know right thank you cheers thank
thank you Mr Gregory man what a great
clip that was now hey hey hey ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nolles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time